tras la decisión sin precedentes del
Gran Jurado de acusar al expresidente
Donald Trump los republicanos hacen un
cerco para respaldarlo Quien fuera su
vicepresidente Mike pence declaró que
todo obedecía a una persecución política
y que la decisión Envía un terrible
mensaje al mundo respecto de la justicia
de su país
Permítame decir que creo que la
acusación sin precedentes de un
expresidente de Estados Unidos por un
tema de financiación de campaña es un
ultraje
y debo decirles Eso debería ser ofensivo
para cada estadounidense izquierda
derecha y centro cada estadounidense
merece el mismo trato bajo la ley y creo
que el pueblo estadounidense verá esto
por lo que es
para el senador republicano Ted Cruz
este proceso es un mal precedente para
el país más presidentes serán procesados
la persecución política de Donald Trump
por parte del fiscal de distrito de
Manhattan Calvin rack pone Estados
Unidos en un muy mal camino
declaraciones que se suman a las del
gobernador de Florida ron de santis
quien si bien se perfila como el gran
oponente de Trump para ganar la
candidatura republicana de 2024 condenó
la acusación contra el expresidente
la militarización del sistema legal para
promover una agenda política pone patas
arriba al Estado de derecho es anti
estadounidense el fiscal de distrito de
Manhattan respaldado por soros ha
torcido constantemente la ley para
degradar los delitos graves y excusar la
Mala conducta criminal los cargos de la
acusación no se han hecho públicos pero
estarían vinculados al supuesto soborno
a la actriz porno stormy Daniels por
130.000 dólares en plena campaña
presidencial de 2016 se espera que Trump
comparezca ante la justicia el próximo
martes